[Music]
during this unsettling new coveted wave
we want to share the latest chapter and
inspiring story of a montana woman we've
been following we introduced you to 35
year old hilary lee a couple of months
ago and she was fighting for her life
she needed a miracle to survive and she
got it meg oliver brings us her story of
hope and gratitude
i'm so excited to see you
this is amazing we first met 35 year old
hillary lee from montana in early
october hillary
your mama's out there on a ventilator an
ecmo machine clinging to life oh my gosh
her mom pamly praying for a miracle
do you remember when we were standing
outside her hospital room and she tried
to wave to you
yeah that was that was um
that was tough the young restaurant
manager was about to get vaccinated when
she got covered my symptoms were so mild
so so so mild so i can't even
i never would have thought i would have
been in that position ever but two weeks
later she was rushed to billings clinic
the fact that we had a bed for her was
nothing short of a miracle kelsey perdue
was hillary's nurse at the time their
icu was overflowing with covid patients
operating at close to 200 percent
capacity you know it's a huge sacrifice
for us to take care of her if she would
not have had ecmo i you know i'm not a
betting person but i don't think she
would have survived how exhausting has
this pandemic been for you
really wears on you thank you hillary's
family was one of those families that i
got really close to in that time
how many times were you there for
her mom
i think really pam was
more there for me i don't think she
would say that but
she would come and visit in the mornings
and
she would really um
sorry i didn't realize i would cry about
this um pam was really ministering to me
after seven agonizing weeks in the
hospital hillary beat the odds answering
her family's prayers
i'm excited
to go home
the day after thanksgiving doctors and
nurses lined the core door as hillary
stepped out on her own
this had to have been such a moment
i knew one day we'd walk out of the
hospital i just didn't know if it would
be with or without her
so it was great i think her brothers
said it best when they told her this
will be the best christmas ever
and it really will be
[Applause]
a christmas to cherish for cbs morning's
meg oliver
[Applause]
what a story hey i feel like applauding
to you i know well done when she got her
body i will share that story i remember
her mom being outside i remember the
nurse but it does put things in
perspective when hillary said my
symptoms were so mild yeah well we're
all trying to smile no big deal you see
how that was a very big deal i have to
be honest you know we're hearing about
omicron and the variant and how the
symptoms are mild yeah my perspective
changed watching that piece and her
saying i went from mild to that image of
her laying in the bed eyes almost rolled
into the back of her head yeah it's
gonna be a great christmas though a
great christmas she's home and healthy
we are happy for you hillary and your
mom shout out to the mama yes yes mama's
always there